the staff hold light that filters
through the trees there's a word for
this in Japanese
and I think it has this kind of ethereal
otherworldly quality to it these soft
shifting patterns of light and Shadow
they're used to create a dream-like
atmosphere in Studio Ghibli films but
it's more than that in the book in
Praise of Shadows junichiro tanizaki
reflects on the beauty of darkness and
shadows and Japanese Aesthetics
especially in contrast to Western
Aesthetics he says westerners they go to
Great pains to direct light where it's
needed and yet they despise what little
Shadows remain Japanese ancestors forced
to live in dark rooms presently came to
discover Beauty in Shadows ultimately to
guide Shadows towards Beauty's ends so
Japanese they treasure their Darkness
instead of hearing it Darkness they know
is the richest source of beauty